the marvel cinematic universe has
managed to do what long was thought
impossible to do in films and television
interconnecting various characters to
build a grander universe tell bigger
stories but also smaller ones as well
i'm starting to wonder if they may have
peaked already
[Music]
hey folks
i want to talk a bit about the current
state of marvel marvel phase 4 at least
um
as we get into this i'm kind of gonna
end up focusing a bit on the disney plus
streaming shows but i do wanna kind of
talk about the state of the thing
overall i'm gonna avoid spoilers for any
of the more recent stuff at time of
recording thor love and thunder has only
recently come out i do have my review up
if you want to see that don't worry i
give a spoiler warning in that before i
get there i will be talking spoiler
stuff in uh at something as recent as
um doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and anything prior to that but
that'll give you a sense of where things
are in this conversation and that also
means phase four is not done it's
debatable how far into it we even are at
this point it's kind of hard to get a
gauge which might be honestly part of
the issue but i'll get there eventually
uh just so we know what we're talking
about let me go over
phase four what has been released so far
what we have dates for and what has been
announced but we don't have distinct
dates on yet so in order of release
phase four has consisted of one division
falcon and the winter soldier loki black
widow what if shang chi eternals hawkeye
spiderman no way home moon knight doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness ms
marvel and thor loving thunder
coming up later this year and getting
into next year we have she-hulk attorney
at law there's the series of i am groot
shorts there were indications that there
was gonna be a halloween special but we
still don't have a title and a date on
that black panther wakanda forever the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
in 2023 we're getting ant-man and the
wasp in quantum mania guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and the marvels which is a
follow-up from captain marvel confirmed
but not yet having any dates set what if
season 2 loki season 2 secret invasion
iron heart armor wars a series set in
wakanda as yet untitled and supposedly a
fantastic four film there's also blade
which has no set release date there's
also the house of harkness and echo
which are spinning off of shows we've
already seen but those have no date and
we don't actually know if they'll be
part of phase four or a theoretical
phase five and there's also
uh
marvel zombies
so that's what i'm talking about when i
talk about marvel phase four
so
what's
the problem first of all let me be clear
problem is relative
the overall apparatus at least for me
doesn't seem to be clicking or moving as
well as it has previously and like let's
be clear as much as i love the mcu and
i've loved how marvel has managed his
properties up to this point the mcu has
not been flawless if you go back and
actually go through everything that
they've done so far you can see where
certain things like had little hiccups
little ideas or notions or plans that
clearly fell apart whether it be casting
changes whether it be things that were
set up and never paid off phases two and
three
went pretty smoothly as far as these
things go or at least managed to have
the appearance of being well planned and
going forward smoothly
then we've hit phase four and things
have been
a little bit wonkier if i were to point
to the first thing that i would say
might be the initial problem it's the
lack of avengers films now i'm kind of
of two minds of this because i get why
they made the decision that they did
which is they have not announced a major
team up film there is no announcement
currently for a new avengers movie the
last one was end game and we have no
more currently announced or planned so
we don't know how they're wrapping up
phase four where the demarcation point
is going to be on all this
and honestly
i get why they made that decision
the avengers film specifically got so
big dealing with the threat of thanos
that by the time that ended we had lost
and then regained half the population of
the entire universe we had dealt with
that major threat we had lost
permanently either through death or the
characters otherwise being retired
major players in this franchise
it's hard to go bigger than that and
continuing in the avengers name
the expectation would be to go big or go
as big but if you keep going that big
even if you can't go much bigger it's
going to as as time goes on
lessen the impact of these things you
take it up to 11 over and over and over
again and it loses its meaning so i
absolutely understand why they have not
had a new avengers film either made or
even announced
at the same time i think what's starting
to become clear at this point is having
the avengers series the team up series
specifically
was kind of a key anchor
because it was the thing that other
things could be building towards or
feeding into but that was also kind of
by design
the franchise that you needed to watch
the other ones for
through definitely phase one and i would
argue most of phases two and three
despite a couple of crossover instances
with specific characters by and large
individual film franchises
were pretty self-contained and could be
watched on their own
there would be things that would
reference events that maybe happened in
avengers or there might be one character
or two who showed up that hadn't been
accounted for but they would get
explained within the context we had take
for example ant-man ant-man has his own
franchise he also showed up in captain
america civil war
he got explained as much as he needed to
be
if you understand that you're watching a
film that is set in a world where there
are this many and possibly even more
superheroes out there then yeah they can
just show up he got as much explanation
as was needed and the plot didn't pivot
on him so it was okay and the ones who
were completely new those being black
panther and spider-man got more time and
got proper introductions again
you could actually watch these things in
a relative just isolation each franchise
and with only a couple of exceptions
like arguably civil war would be one for
the most part it was really only the
avengers
that you needed to have watched a bunch
of other stuff to properly appreciate
but even then
if you weren't a fan of let's say thor
you could watch the other shows and then
watch avengers or avengers age of ultron
or the later avengers films and still
get his deal without having to watch his
movies
they were the central pillar around
which everything else revolved
we don't have that anymore
and as a result the interconnectedness
is starting to feel
more essential or possibly
less
well thought out since there is not that
central pillar where everybody's going
to come together characters are showing
up in each other's franchises a bit more
casually which in and of itself is not
necessarily a problem
but it doesn't feel like it's building
towards something the way it used to
and part of that also has to do with the
overall
story
that we have going here now in hindsight
lots of people look at the infinity saga
as some people have chosen to label
um the
phases one through three
as building towards endgame and
they honestly didn't not towards the
tail end they dropped little things that
could be picked up later and eventually
i think it was more in the favor of
infinity war and end game that they were
able to take everything that had been
done and make it seem as if it had all
been building to this one thing even
though a lot of it was just tiny drop
stuff little throwaway lines here and
there that didn't
do much
by themselves but all those pieces got
gathered up into a greater hole
here
we don't have that
the closest we have to that is the
concept of the multiverse
but that's being used in ways that don't
feel like they're building to anything
they're being used in ways that are
actually very isolated and
self-contained the multiverse
effectively got introduced in loki well
i've arguably even created in loki or
recreated
it depends on how much you want to
believe uh
kang
in terms of his explanation of what was
going on
but assuming that all that is accurate
that basically kick-started the
multiverse and so since then we've had a
couple of multiverse movies the big ones
being spiderman norway home and doctor
stranger the multiverse of madness
and those in theory connect to each
other
except they kind of don't
now normally as i kind of said before
that's not a huge deal you don't have to
have the spider-man directly impacting
or be dependent upon doctor strange or
vice versa like that's a good thing they
should be more self-contained except
that when they're both dealing
fundamentally with the exact same core
concept
shouldn't they feel
like
there's more of a point to it happening
in more than one place like the way the
multiverse was used and the way it
impacts things in spider-man is not the
same way that it was used and impacted
things in doctor strange is not the same
way that it was introduced in loki which
doesn't feel like how it was explored in
what if
and right now these disparate ways that
the multiverse is being explored just
feel like
well they just feel like it they're
running out the concept
as opposed to
going anywhere
this might be a situation in which
marvel's being hoisted by their own
petard a little bit because the way in
which they managed to build the first
three phases to make it seem like it was
always building towards something
greater the fact that we're not really
getting that sense now makes it feel
like an absence whereas if we were
starting with phase 4 maybe it wouldn't
be such an issue
but we have the previous phases for
comparison
and it does feel like something's
missing now as i said the ways in which
these things are interconnecting is
being handled a bit differently than it
was before in a way that i think is
actually starting to
very directly hurt some of the
storytelling especially
when it comes to the
series the disney plus streaming series
so the first one of those we had was one
division now one division was a really
interesting concept it was one of the
few to have nine most of these only get
six episodes interestingly looking at it
the ones that um either have had or are
going to have nine episodes appear to be
the ones that at least for part of their
run are more episodic because one
division starting out these were fairly
isolated episodes as they explored
different decades of sitcoms but then as
it moved forward it started to build
more of a coherent overarching
serialized story the other one that has
already aired that had nine episodes was
what if which again started out being
very um episodic and became serialized
towards the finale and then
we are supposed to get nine episodes for
she-hulk attorney at law now that hasn't
aired at the time that i'm talking but i
would be shocked if that's not handled
episodically basically with jennifer
walters aka she-hulk handling a new case
every episode so the ones that seem
designed to just be a serialized story
are getting six episodes ones that have
at least partly an episodic structure
are being given nine
but coming back to one division i did
a rather lengthy dissection of that you
can check that there
my main issue was with the ending and
i've complained about the ending in a
different context before my issue with
the ending initially was that
it really felt like agatha harkness as a
fact that there was an external villain
at all felt
very strange
because
the villain seemed to be
by design of the story wanda's inability
to properly and healthily cope with her
own grief and she was not taking into
account the way that how she was trying
to cope was hurting other people
that was kind of the villain or at the
very least that was the problem but then
i don't know where a villain shows up
and we have a wizard duel in the sky and
it felt so jarring and i really i didn't
like it at the time but i like it even
less as time goes on
initially i chalked that up to just some
misguided notion that all these things
have to end in action seeds and i'm not
going to say that isn't in the mix it
probably still is
but having now seen doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness there's
another factor
wanda had to be set up to have the dark
hold
and in the extra scene at the very end
of that show to be messing around with
it in a sinister fashion
so that she could be the villain
in doctor strange of the multiverse of
madness
it
feels very much at this point
like the entire
i'd say last two two and a half episodes
of wanda vision aren't there because
they're the natural extension or
conclusion of the story of wanda's grief
but because we have to create a
situation where she gets the dark hold
and we can set up as the villain for
next time and we can drop this whole
prophecy about the scarlet witch
because none of that stuff benefits the
story of wanda vision
at all
and like look sometimes the
interconnectedness stuff doesn't
immediately benefit the story that it's
in but when you hinge the ending of the
show on it well you're making it a
massive part of it this isn't an easter
egg
this is what you've twisted the story
into being
in order to set up other stuff
i'm finding myself having similar
concerns with moon knight and ms marvel
now to be fair at the time that i'm
recording this ms marvel has not had its
final episode yet however even if its
final episode is great
it still feels very much like it is
being designed as just
a way to cover the origin of kamala khan
before she shows up in the marvels next
year
it doesn't actually feel like it has
that much of a story to tell about
kamala khan about ms marvel
it's covering a lot of lore
is what it's doing and it started out
being about her and focusing on her and
her family and her social life and her
interests and her as a person and then
it became
family history
lore dumps villains who were really
oddly and
in some ways very under-motivated
introducing characters and having them
betray her immediately or get killed
almost immediately and it just feels
like a rushed attempt to cover an origin
story because they decided to give her a
series instead of a movie and similarly
with moon knight that one was a case
where the rush basically all hit at the
tail end whereas ms marvel assuming that
the final episode is great i would like
it to be but even if it is the
everything crushed together and really
weird pacing and this isn't flowing well
is in about the middle episodes three
four five whereas moon knight basically
all got crammed into the tail end and
with moon knight as with wanda vision a
forced ending with a villain that does
not feel like the natural conclusion for
this story about a man trying to sort
out his own head
it's a little less jarring than it was
in one division but not by much
the
series that have have worked the best so
far or at least the smoothest are the
ones that dealt with pre-existing
characters quite heavily with one
division being the big exception but
i've already gone over why that is so
that's falcon and the winter soldier
which at least in terms of fitting into
the greater world the greater mcu
i think is probably the best one i'm not
saying that it is like my favorite or
that it's you know the most rewarding or
the best show but strictly in terms of
logistically fitting in i feel like
that's the best one by a bit because it
tells a fairly completed story and it
feels like it's telling a completed
story and ends with sam having taken on
the mantle of captain america so that
when the next captain america movie
happens he can already be captain
america and if people want to know how
he got to the point where he was
comfortable with the shield well here's
the show but you can also start there
since he was given the shield at the end
of end game and you could theoretically
skip the show and get the gist of what
might have gone on in terms of well
something happened where he's now
comfortable having this mantle cool you
want the details here's a show that i
feel like slots in the best overall
loki
is probably my favorite in terms of
enjoyment
and it's also a little bit of an odd
duck because it's one of the only ones
along with what if that is supposedly
getting a second season at least so far
although interestingly loki was not
originally planned to have a second
season that was something that was
determined as they were working on it it
was originally conceived to just be a
one-off like
everything else
but it exists in this weird realm of
being fairly standalone but also
introducing the idea of the multiverse
except that when the multiverse has come
up in other things as well it gets
reintroduced in things like no way home
and multiverse of madness so did it even
really need to be set up here was it
necessary but with something like say
hawkeye it feels a little bit like a way
to sign off clint if the if they feel
like they're done with that character it
doesn't introduce a new character to be
fair but she's existing within the realm
of established characters so it it still
has that ground foundation that the
stronger entries have right now the ones
that feel like they're on the weakest
footing are the ones that are
introducing new characters
and i can't help but wonder if it's
because they're being introduced not to
have their own shows but
just
to be able to
have them show up in the movies later
and for their to be an explanation
which is
something that i've cautioned about
before and i've been i'm now
legitimately concerned
that marvel is doing which is to
create movies
where having watched the shows
is kind of essential
it's arguable that they've already done
that with multiverse of madness to
really understand what is going on with
wanda like it gets a little bit of an
explanation
in that movie but not much and it feels
like a huge leap
from
where she was last seen in the films
like yes she was grieving the loss of
vision but
how did we get here
and while i have argued already that
they took her too sharply into villainy
um you do at least understand how things
got here purely logistically if you've
seen wanda vision but if not
what's going on
and i strongly feel that this one is
going to be similarly with the uh
introduction of kamala khan
in the marvels
and possibly similarly if we ever get
kate bishop in the films or if moon
knight shows up again i can't help but
feel that these characters are just
going to show up with little to no
explanation and basically a token line
establishing where they might have come
from or what they did last time which
starts to become the film equivalent of
something to comic son of ages which is
to put a little asterisk when characters
in dialogue reference something that the
reader might not know to find out more
check out issues
of this series
which
in theory is part of the nature of the
interconnectedness
but leaning on it that hard to the point
where you start to feel like it's
punishing you
uh with a lack of understanding if you
haven't followed everything
that's part of what turned me off of
comics back in the 90s
because the 90s were notorious about
really leading into that way too damn
hard
i don't know what it's like now i never
really properly got back on them i read
graphic novels uh on occasion but this
is also a problem i've started running
into already with star wars
because to pull an example
the book of boba fett
which i watched because
i like boba fett
i like the idea of boba fett i was
interested to see what they were going
to do with him i know him from the
movies i don't watch all of the star
wars shows i never have i've seen some
of them a lot of them haven't grabbed me
and so when i sat down to watch
something called the book of boba fett i
was actually largely enjoying it for the
most part and then suddenly it turned
into the mandalorian season 2.5
and as someone who hadn't yet watched
the second season of the mandalorian
i was really annoyed
and wondering why the hell is this here
and then towards the very end they
introduce a villain who i guess is a
huge deal if you followed the star wars
cartoons the clone wars and rebels and
things of that nature but who i didn't
know
but was framed very clearly as someone
who i was supposed to know but i didn't
and so i felt like enjoyment was stolen
from me as punishment for not having
been a good fan and absorbing everything
even if
i didn't particularly gravitate for
towards it or feel like it clicked for
me i was supposed to watch it all and if
i didn't i wasn't gonna know what was
going on
star wars has already started to dip
that way for me
and i'm now starting to legitimately get
worried about marvel doing the same
thing and even though i do watch all the
marvel stuff
that's just not healthy
creatively
now i don't want it to sound all like
all doom and gloom i don't want people
to think ah
bear hates phase four i don't there's
some of it i really like and honestly
i'd say the best thing about phase four
so far is they have been willing to
bring in
directors who and allowing them to put
their unique vision on it more that was
something that was
uh honestly not really there in phase
one almost at all
because the directors while all of them
did good work none of them really put a
particularly unique stamp except for
arguably joss whedon on the first
avengers but then later on bringing in
someone like james gunn to do guardians
of the galaxy marvel has started to open
up about that with then later getting a
ryan coogler for black panther but even
as they did things like that they were
relying on people with a big history in
television
to handle sort of the main thing
that's where the russo brothers came
from who took over for captain america
and then later the avengers films and i
think that was actually a very smart
move for the way things were working at
that point because as television
directors they were used to
just coming in and taking characters and
story lines and component parts that
were already in the works from other you
know points that had already been
established and figuring out what to do
with them as opposed to expecting to put
their own unique stamp on every step of
the way
but as we've gone forward and entered
into phase four i think they've made
some really interesting directing picks
and have let directors make films that
feel like their own
whether you feel those have all worked
for you or not i don't know but i feel
like i can see the influence of
chloe zao on eternals taika watiti on
love and thunder granted he got
established in phase three with ragnarok
but love and thunder feels even more
taika ytt than that one did and
especially sam raimi with multiverse of
madness for all my issues with that
movie what is best about it is what he
brings as a director he brings
fantastic
horror energy to that movie and pretty
much everything that's good about it
ties into that
so
marvel is stretching its legs a little
bit in terms of allowing directors
a little bit more freedom in terms of
molding something to be theirs
and that's good because you can look
back to stories of phases two or three
where some really interesting and or
up-and-coming directors
talked with marvel but ultimately didn't
do anything with them because they felt
that
they weren't going to be able to express
what they wanted on the project and
given that someone like sam raimi hasn't
touched comic books since spider-man 3
and hasn't even really touched
big-budget filmmaking in a dang long
time the fact that they could court him
back and he came out of it going i had a
really great time working on this to me
says they are
possibly shifting to becoming more
director-centric and allowing directors
to put more of their own voice in it
which is a good thing
however i can't wonder if that
doesn't tie back to what i said before
about there being a lack of that central
pillar without a core guiding thing like
the avengers series of films were and
like the infinity saga was for
everything else to be formed around
maybe allowing directors
longer leashes
is the only way to breathe more life
into things because if there still was a
core central thing that everything
needed to be in
congruence with then maybe you wouldn't
want people stretching out as far
that's speculation on my part i don't
know
but i will say that
all these things that i've talked about
all these factors the
lack of a clear purpose a clear thing
that's being built towards
yet still
banking increasingly on the
interconnectedness
when it doesn't seem to be
building to a purpose
seems to almost be for its own sake
it's starting to feel like
the machinery is grinding the gears are
not fitting together as smoothly
as they used to and again they didn't
fit perfectly smoothly before but they
were very good at kind of glossing over
when things
you know had little shutters
it's harder to get
as unambiguously excited as i used to
about future marvel pro projects
just because i'm looking at the way that
the interconnectedness
is impacting them
and it doesn't excite me it's starting
to feel
almost obligatory
like can we connect these things great
do it
but what if the story you want to tell
is
better done
without connecting these things
and
for my money the ones that i've enjoyed
the most
haven't had a lot of connections to
other things
multiverse of madness probably have the
strongest that's the film i've liked the
least in phase four
i actually like thor love and thunder
the best
appears to be a bit of a
controversial opinion but
it stands on its own and i love it for
that i think in many ways i'm looking
back at end game and feeling like
that would have been a good place to
stop
i'm not saying i wish marvel had
but that did
true to its name
feel like an ending
it didn't have to be a definitive ending
obviously it left things in place and
characters in place for stories to
continue
but in that way that it's like okay but
the big important thing happened now
we're just kind of
playing out what people are doing in the
aftermath
and there isn't anything inherently
wrong with that
but it does feel
less important
less momentous
a little bit less exciting
so those are my rambly thoughts and
concerns and sort of where i'm at with
phase four of the marvel cinematic
universe
i still intend to check these things out
as they come out and i hope to like
all of them but
i'm getting nervous
about the streaming shows especially
because those are really starting to
feel like
they are being built
as
support structures for the films
as opposed to ways to actually explore
these characters fully on their own
and in the cases where they start to do
that they get
kneecapped
in order to fit the
films better like with one division
potentially like with ms marvel again
we've got to see how that plays out but
i'm nervous i want to like these i
actually it helped a lot seeing thor
love and thunder and again i know a lot
of people don't like it i'm still kind
of weird on why but that energized me a
lot actually
that helped
and hopefully i really like she-hulk
because i love that character
but we'll see
there's some good strong stuff coming
out so far chongqi was great i
definitely want to see more from him
eternals was interesting
if not quite landing perfectly but it
was weird in a way that i enjoyed but
black widow felt like a footnote and
something that should have been in phase
three
multiverse of madness
frustrated me and more as time goes on
no way home fun as it was was more of a
celebration of its own individual
franchise than anything else and again
enjoyable
but hard to take as a consideration for
where things go from here
i don't know
what are your thoughts on the state of
marvel phase four whatever they are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
like share and subscribe patreon is what
pays the bills that enables me to do
this as my living and to
sit around thinking about and then
talking about and then editing all my
thoughts on these to share with you
folks any amount you are able to support
is of great assistance
um but even if you can't
the likes and shares and subscribes help
me out there's other things you can
follow me on besides this twitch i have
novels i'm on tick-tock et cetera et
cetera et cetera
don't worry too much about it though
because what i want you to remember
ultimately
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks to my highest supporting
patrons robin moore zubin lutfullah
barack the thing that goes doink in the
anime oliver b melinda walters andelke
the oath of boyd bernabby lacks the
poodle zach idolin tracy scravit angry
casper bookworm adam rdl taylor shane
ross ring borlay brendan the rose and tt
you want to hear me possibly butcher
your name check out the rewards on the
patreon
and thanks to all you friends
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]